[Music]
thank you all so much for being here and
thanks for the warm welcome of course
absolutely it's it's it's not just like
when you release a movie it's an event
like we wait a few years for you to do
this and I don't I don't mean to you
know beg you to work faster but please
do I I want to work faster great work
faster let's get to work that's work
we're working on something right now um
whenever I have people has accomplish as
any of you I actually love to go back to
the beginning and ask what was your
first job in this business like did you
start in a mail room or you know the
first thing you wrote or the first time
you felt you could call yourself a
filmmaker I'm going answer that first uh
I was an extra in uh a spaghetti western
that was shot in Spain I was 16 years
old my first job did you think you
wanted to be an actor or I thought for a
moment that I could be an actor and then
uh in college I studied acting I I
realized two very important made two
important decisions one was that I
wasn't any good but more importantly I
realized I didn't want it badly enough
to make myself good so I said all right
what can I do as a failed actor so I
tried
producing he's in Dr shago by the way he
uh touches Julie Christie's arm as she's
leaving a party right that's exact are
you being serious believe you remember
that I'd forgotten it you made an
impression you made a very profound
impression oh my gosh is incredible um
sorry David you have to top that now uh
I can't but I my first gig was um I this
is my second career and I did something
before this and I kind of quit into
nothing because I I couldn't do what I
was doing before and I and I just wanted
to be a writer so badly so I ended up
getting a my first gig was uh a job on a
show and I don't know if anybody
remembers this a show Nickelodeon called
the aventures of Pete and Pete of course
uh any remember that so it was me
Viscardi mcrob and Joe stelman the four
of us writing that show and it was just
a revelation it was so great cuz they
had like Madonna was on it and like RM
was a kid show Nickelodeon it was this
really Insurgent fantastic kid show so I
feel really fortunate to have that be my
my first gig wow for you so I was at
UCLA film school and while at UCLA film
school I got a job through a friend in
Omaha who had a nephew who owned a
business in Woodland Hills called
Keepsake video and I shot and edited uh
weddings Bar Mitzvah bot mitzvah
and uh wedding anniversaries wow that's
amaz what great like practice though
because you were actually working in the
business you were directing an editing
yeah and and and witnessing you know
real life yeah that's amazing probably
doesn't sound very glamorous now but I
think that's incredible like similar
when I later in film school I was a
catering waiter really for years and uh
also you get to be a you know a fly on
thewall in these events in Los Angeles
wow yeah
um well now here you all all are with
the holdovers uh such a beautiful movie
and again like such such a great slice
of humanity um you're obviously known
for your funny unique insightful films
about The Human Experience but this is
different in that you actually didn't
write the screenplay but what was sort
of the initial sparker idea that that
caused you to pair with
David I had had the idea of this the
premise for about a dozen years and had
done nothing with it it was on my list
and then some years ago I received a TV
pilot excuse me a TV pilot set in a
boarding
school contemporary story wait it set in
1988 yeah but I want to reread that by
the way read that pil it's pretty good
it's all right anyway I didn't want to
make it but so I called him up and I
said hey man I just read your script I
think it's really good I don't want to
do it but would you consider writing
something in that same world for me a
feature film and he said yes that's how
we met immediately immediately yeah I
was going to ask was it an instant yes I
thought it was a joke I thought it was
my buddy Bob messing with me he would
call me up he' occasionally be like
David hemingson I want to you know we've
told this story a couple times we've
told the story a couple times but I want
to at some point I just wanted to say he
agreed to do it on spec really without I
mean for a minute we without do we who
here wouldn't work with him on spec yeah
but you never know how it's going to
work no but for a minute it's like well
should we try to set this up and get you
paid and you know give it some validity
and it's like and it kind of didn't work
out with that one uh Finance year Studio
we approached and then he's like it
I got some money we can so thanks again
for doing that thank you again for doing
that can always go you know I wanted to
honor the time he was putting into it
and I'm so glad it paid off every single
moment of it honestly and it sounds it's
just the truth every single moment of it
was a great pleasure I mean you know you
get to work with this filmmaker so you
you it was great and it was like going
to film School in his back because to to
kind of keep up with him to understand
him I had to I had to do some serious
research and cinile video guys who knows
copile video Corner Santa Monica and
satel JP and Greg greatest video store
in the world Film School used to work
there that's crazy I did yeah I worked
there for a while that's insane uh I do
want to ask you though because you
obviously have an extensive career in
television had you ever written a
feature screenplay before yeah I mean
I've I've written a couple features but
you know they were not they I I sold one
in like 2009 but it was sort of like I
I did a lot of TV you know I've been
I've been a showrunner for for a while
I've been in TV for like 27 years so
like I was paying the mortgage and and
when this opportunity kind of came along
I'm like absolutely but I knew I had up
my game and that's why I talking about
actually doing the research and he's a
phen phenomenal collaborator I mean we'd
have this these tremendous conversations
and and uh I feel like I got educated
and I got to write the movie at the same
time and it was kind of a dream come
true to be totally honest with you you
know what's that pilot doing now because
I say spin-off I think it's possible
it's just sitting on my shelf I don't
know we'll see I'd like to reread it by
the way it's good man you like years ago
just I know I just don't remember it any
want to buy this
pilot uh Mark you've previously
collaborated with Alexander um and I'm
curious is it is it a matter of you know
whatever he's doing you're interested
are you waiting for that call or when
did he first start to approach you about
the idea for the
holdovers well I I've known Alexander
for some time we' never worked together
but we run into each other at events and
and then we started to develop a
actually a short story a Spanish
language short story we both speak
Spanish and uh it was going really well
and Alexander had uh told me about this
movie called downsizing and asked me if
I wanted to produce it it was H once
again like you I'm I Pro my yes was
probably quicker than yours so uh and
then um we uh we obviously keep in touch
talk all the time and uh started to tell
me about about this one I never met met
David but you as soon as I read it I
knew I knew I had to be a part of it I
mean every I we have to talk about this
amazing Ensemble because every role is
so perfectly cast and sometimes with
brand new faces but obviously I think
everyone's been waiting for you to
reunite with Paul Giamatti were you just
waiting for the perfect role yes and did
was this written for him yes so David
you knew when you were writing it that
did you have PA yeah I mean it was like
a threshold conversation uh right around
the whole the 1970 of it all we had a
kind of a threshold conversation about
what year would we sit in and then there
was a tonal thing and I think the third
thing we talked about was he's like how
do you feel about Paul Gman I'm like I
love Paul Gman he's like would you like
toite we we should absolutely do that so
we ran to I ran toward that immediately
yeah and named the character Paul named
him Paul and the weird thing is Paul's
dad and my dad knew each other in
college which is a really weird thing um
and I found out from his dad when I was
graduating from college uh so it's the
crazy go to Yale too he went toale so
you're second generation Yale yeah yeah
yeah uh with some people would say it's
like dangerous to write with an actor in
mind but you obviously knew he was going
to do this yeah and he's like you know
he's I can't think of anything he can't
do he's sort of like a you know he's
like a he's like Swiss army knife he's
got so many gears you know he he
definitely so many attributes and you
know this felt like he was wheelhouse I
I was a huge student of Alexander's work
I kind of saturated myself in his movies
before I even met him so I was sort of
like I and I love sideways I mean who
doesn't love sideways so I'm like you
see him do that I'm like well I'm pretty
certain and he said to you didn't he
said I know that I know that these guys
because of his his AC his background
Paul yeah when when he read the script
Paul a product himself of Cho and Yale
said yeah I know that I knew these guys
yeah and I suspected he might because
we're both we're both from New Haven we
were both born in New Haven and as it
turns out our fathers knew each other
but it's like I kind of had an inkling
that he might get it and he'd get it
immedately who else could have I can't
think I'm hard pressed to think who else
else could have played the part someone
to me the other day said you know in his
prime Richard draus could have played it
well okay I think like Charles lton oh
maybe could have played it I mean you
know each one would have put a different
spin on it so you knew you had
contemporarily I don't know I can't
think of a single person who could have
done this I don't know you knew you had
Paul who's amazing but this film also
hinges on the casting of Dominic cessa
who as soon as I saw this movie I wanted
to learn everything about him and I
can't because apparently this is his
first professional job he had never even
been in a short film before nothing zero
he was an actual senior at Deerfield
Academy in Deerfield Mass when we shot
playing a junior at basically Deerfield
Academy had he done school plays or
anything like that okay so he audition
in the like a star of the drama
Department theater department and he had
you know want wanted to be an actor he's
now I mean he was a senior when we shot
he was applying to NYU and Carnegie
melon and brand I or whatever those
undergrad schools that have such good
acting programs so he was on his way
yeah but anyway now he's really got a
career I got a movie out of the deal and
he got a career out of the
deal how many people do you estimate you
saw for this
role I personally did not see I saw
maybe 70 or 80 but the casting director
and her staff saw 800 wow that's I mean
70 and 80 is a lot too I have to say
well you don't watch the whole
audition it's true the secret it's so
nice you know you watch about 15 seconds
like yeah next you know the cane comes
out was there a moment where you knew
you had something special with him when
you were watching that tape something he
did or that that caught your
attention he had the hair M no I know
exactly what you mean if he hadn't had
the
hair you know it he we saw especially
Susan shopmaker the casting director she
saw CU she had been in the room with him
I just saw a tape the first time and she
had driven out to Deerfield from New
York and auditioned him and she was he's
really got something special and just
look at him and there's something in
there and but the trouble with his first
couple of auditions was he had never
auditioned for anything before so he
thought he kind of had to
perform
and Cinema doesn't like performing
especially if you maybe make the wrong
choice so and so sue like no no no no
just stay with him let's let's beat that
performative stuff out of him for a
minute and so we brought him in probably
four five six seven times and the last
time finally with Paul Giamatti and got
him just relax we see you inside we can
see through you and you've got something
but I didn't realize the degree to which
he had something which was a fully
formed from the head of
Zeus film actor not just actor but film
actor and uh you know Paul and I were
conspiring to uh you know well let's
help the kid out and you know you're Mr
experienced film actor and you can help
him help keep him relaxed and give him
tips and so forth he didn't really need
any tips on once he sort of got the you
know we pushed him into the wave and
then he just surfed you know
remark you could just do anything the uh
his arguably his most impressive scene
or hardest scene is right after he sees
his father and in the restaurant and
it's a long continuous shot on him when
he talks about quite frankly opens uh
opens up his heart and soul that's the
that's the first take that we have in W
amazing knew it perfectly and that's his
performance I look at it every time I'm
just my my uh my jaw drops
however that he had we had auditioned
with that scene yeah the big monologue
so he was very well rehearsed in it by
the time I mean it's still got to be
fresh on the day you shoot and
everything but he we had been over and
over and over that that monologue many
times I actually I I want to point out
because this movie not only feels like a
movie from the 70s I mean well it's a
movie set in the 70s but it feels like
it's in the 70s like even like the pops
and the crackles and everything and I do
want to point out that you know it's a
period piece um you have a pretty
sizable cast and you're doing this on an
independent film budget um how did you
make it so authentic and then maybe this
is a question for Mark you know within
that
budget honey what would you
say um well independent film
budget so it was low by American
Standards we're not supposed to say how
much it was low by American Standards
but not so low that we couldn't do
anything you know uh but I've never had
a huge I mean downsizing was an
exception but all the other films I've
made have been you know lowbudget by
American Standards High by European
stand standards or Asian standards but
by you know I did down uh wait was it
Nebraska 10 years ago that was like a
$13 million budget you know chump change
for these people s ways was 15 and a
half 16 descendants George Clooney
Hawaii still like low 20s wow so I've
never had the big you know he budgets
and Schmid Schmidt was pretty low too
Schmidt was 32 million but half of that
was Jack
Nicholson So Below the line was still
you know 15 16 million wow and having to
build sets because Nicholson only shoots
eight hours so you have to do a lot of
stuff on stage and oh man anyway
total the the the is the discipline it's
taught me over the years is is precise
camera placement and then doing as like
really being as disciplined as I can I
mean that's the that's the beauty of
having low budgets is it forces a type
of I mean I hope a type of Elegance but
certainly discipline about staging as
much as you can in each shot you also I
must say you also know exactly what you
want I watched you very carefully and
like you know we didn't blow our days
and this the vibe on set is really great
I mean it's it's a very calm and lovely
set to be on uh having been on 27 years
of television sets I can to test it out
well and and the other thing too about
experience
is uh you think oh I've got a low budget
I have to make all my days and you know
you're I'm sure many of you work in film
you're allowed 12 hour 10 hours and then
12 hours then but you often go to 14
hours
I rarely do more than about nine or 10
hours really in a given day and that
just comes
from to some degree not always but
sometimes knowing what I want but also
having a good crew I mean if you have
good grip in electric then you can do it
yeah and if you have good act I mean in
this one that's the good thing too about
Dominic cessa is he could memorize I
could do oners I could do lot you know
two three four pages of dialogue with
him and Paul especially toward the back
half of the film when they're in Boston
like in the liquor store that that's
four pages of dialogue in one shot and
then on the street afterwards and after
the winning ticket bar uh scene you know
when they're walking and talking to do
those in single takes those you can do
th those shorten your days but you can
do that only if you have the actors who
can you know a cook is only as good as
his or her ingredients so I had good
ingredients but I have noticed that like
some of our best actors do give their
greatest performances under your
direction and I'm curious about your
language with actors I demand
it well actually let me ask Mark because
you've worked with so many URS like
Steven Soderberg and Clint Eastwood
you've seen people who work with actors
what makes Alexander
special let's not compare no so Clint
Eastwood and then Alexander Bay yeah
this this is a hard one actually not at
all to answer he is probably the most
prepared director and the most self
confident director I've ever worked with
so we know that we're never in question
about what we're doing what's required
of us what it is he needs not that he's
uh he's necessarily easy in terms of his
requirements but you always know what it
is he needs to make a scene work and
days that should have taken forever and
we should have gone into excessive
overtime he never did sometimes we
finished uh finished early and it's so
consequently everybody was it was
probably the happiest set I've ever been
on that is absolutely the truth yeah how
did you develop that language with
actors how do you develop a language
with
actors I don't
know and maybe we you talk about sort of
an early desire to be an actor oneself
so I don't think I'm necessarily very I
could do a couple of Parts kind of
Clowny Parts I'm a better clown than
actor I think but uh I just sort of know
how it should be given that actor more
or less certainly the Rhythm and
uh I
I before directing Jack Nicholson I
called up Mike Nichols yeah and I'm
proud to name drop and say he was he
took an interest in me early on and he
was a friend and just a lovely guy and
befriended a lot of young directors who
was very generous that way anyway before
doing a about Schmid I called him up and
I said oh Mike Nichols you who have
directed Jack Nicholson three or four
times what advice do you have for me and
he said oh that's easy my boy just tell
him the
truth because he's going to smell it on
you
anyway and that's something that I've
taken with me directing All actors you
know you take directing classes in in
film school it's like give them actable
verbs
and don't give them line readings and uh
don't tell them a result like I can't
think of all that stuff I can't think of
a great active verb I sometimes have to
say or I'll say do it like this you know
like Charlie Chaplain the only way he
could direct is to act it out for him
and then say imitate
me and you kind of just have to do that
I mean even Jack Nicholson told me years
ago if you gotta if don't don't be
afraid to give me a line reading
especially since you've written it
because it tells me the rhythm you're
looking for it's a pretty good Jack by
the way well you know no I've talked to
so many you just tell these people the
truth and I mean there's you know
William Wier famously who directed more
actors to Oscar winning performance
certainly nominated but Oscar winning
performances more than any other
director to date didn't know what to
tell actors all he would say is I don't
know just do it
better you know the the thing is I don't
want to I'm sorry if this is longwinded
pleas but during action and cut I'm the
audience I'm I'm sitting in the audience
watching the movie you know everybody
else is focusing on his or her specialty
is the hair right is the costume right
you know is the boom microphone in the
right place whatever it is I'm the one
watching the movie so I'm like cut I
don't buy
it that was too slow man do it faster or
hit that other word not this one or
something and you just sort of I think
it just comes from feeling a movie yeah
but also feeling a movie is is the other
side of it like did it feel like a movie
but also if there were no film equipment
here and this were actually happening
would I believe it you know do I feel
like I'm there with real people doing
real things and so when those two things
click in that it's like oh I feel that
that's really happening in front of me
and that has the Rhythm for a movie then
you know then we can move on there's
this Min misnomer that actors don't like
line readings but every actor I've ever
spoken to says they actually really do
prefer it they're like don't give me
flowery language just tell me how to say
it I'll often tell actors I don't have a
brilliant actable verb for
you just do it more like this and the
other thing too is they always say don't
give results result s why not I need you
to be sad here how you get there is part
of your internal process in fact if I
try to give you some actable verb I
might screw up whatever you got going on
inside you already so you know you don't
have to cry I I'm not going to make you
you have to cry but I mean and if
they've read the damn script they know
what's what's going on and I think
you're talking about like you have this
incredible nose for for falsity like you
know do I buy it and I think you know we
talk about this a lot like you sitting
in the audience and looking and going
like you know almost like almost a
documentarian like what is the accurate
Human Experience what resonates as a as
a true Human Experience and I think that
that is born out in all the performances
you get out of these well yeah not
what's the movie version what's the real
version but then it's weird how the real
version intersects with the movie I
don't know how to explain it any better
I um I'm so sorry that we're out of time
because I know you all have we're just
getting started I have no place to be
sleeping bag I do want to remind the
audience though that the holdovers is
going to be in theaters in New York and
LA on October 27th before Day After
Tomorrow Nationwide please spread the
word it's such a special film thank you
so much for being here tonight thanks
for coming you we didn't take any
questions from the
[Music]
audience